[Music]
starring joking phoenix
joker is still the most successful
r-rated film of all time
the alternate story around batman's
favorite villain thrilled viewers around
the globe and has gained even more
popularity due its social controversies
since then fans have been eagerly
awaiting part two after all
todd phillips had already announced that
joker 2 was coming
a new clue could be a statement from
warner brothers that mainly revolves
around the black superman movie the
report includes talk of
joker and its planned sequel so
officials haven't given up on the sequel
yet
in terms of content at least that would
fit quite well
because the end of the first part
certainly leaves some room for
speculation
of course we will keep you up to date on
further news about
joker 2.
after reporting last week on the first
shots of the actress from the new hbo
series house of the dragon the official
twitter account now gives us another
glimpse
of the game of thrones prequel this time
not only in the studio but properly
staged we see
among others princess rhaenyra prince
daemon targaryen
the sea snake as well as alison and otto
hightower
the five of them formed the core of the
new series and are the most important
actors around the power struggle in the
house of targaryen
which almost 300 years before game of
thrones was clearly more powerful than
we know it from the hbo series so far
their only enemy in maintaining power is
themselves which is why daemon and
ranura are two rival candidates for the
succession to the throne of king viserys
the first
the entire thing then results in nothing
less than an extremely
brutal civil war which will be more
familiar to many under its name
dance of the dragons who will ultimately
secure the throne is something you can
expect to find out
next year but unfortunately there is no
exact release date for a house of the
dragon yet
tom cruise acting is not only associated
with long running hits like top gun or
jack reacher but above all with his
self-performed stuns on set but the 50
year old is
anything but stiff is impressively
proven by director christopher mccrory
in a snapshot from mission impossible 7.
in his signature role as ethan hunt cruz
is seen hanging from an obviously moving
train
this may not quite compare to his
climbing stun on the burj khalifa or the
daring spin on a plane taking off but
wherever chris's name is attached the
us-american
obviously still gives it to go himself
the train motif
is particularly exciting because in the
very first mission impossible park from
1996 crews delivered a fight with a
helicopter in a threatening final scene
on the roof of a moving tgv
rumor has that the filming of mission
impossible 7 almost ended fatally for
one of the cameramen who slipped off the
moving train during the shoot and was
rescued by tom cruise at the last second
thus things are heating up during the
shooting of mission impossible 7 and we
are already looking forward to the
release on may
2022 some days ago marvel surprised us
with a three minute trailer of its
upcoming project
in the clip you can see not only the
first video footage of the eternals but
also titles for black panther 2 at
captain marvel 2.
the former will have the official title
black panther wakanda forever and will
begin filming shortly
as we learned a few weeks ago the late
chadwick boseman will not be making a
cgi appearance for the sequel
whether michael b jordan will return as
killmonger remains unclear
and is also unlikely due to the busy
actors packed schedule
captain marvel 2 also has a new title
namely the marvels
this is of course a clear indication
that captain marvel will receive
active support from miss marvel now that
filming on the miss marvel series is
already in full swing anyway
her friend monica rambo who was last
seen in one division could also play a
role
also mentioned in marvel's new trailer
all black widow spider-man no way home
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness we are all looking forward to
the new mcu blockbusters of which black
widow will be their first to hit
theaters on july 9
2021 in the first two transformers
movies
lead actress megan fox was without
question at the peak of her career she
was then succeeded by rosie huntington
whiteley and nikola pelz whereas hailee
steinfeld was firmly cast in the prequel
bumblebee
as deadline now reports the candidate
for transformer 6 is
also already as good as set dominique
fishback is said to be in the closing
stages of contract negotiations with
paramount
the 30 year old may be familiar to many
from the netflix film project power or
the hbo series the deuce
so will she join anthony reymus as the
leading actress in the new transformers
movie
in addition to deadlines relatively
solid information reimus and fishback
have also been friends for a couple of
years and more or less launched their
carriers together providing yet
another reason for the new york actress
to sign on the work behind the scenes is
being handled by director stephen kappel
jr and screenwriters darnell mataya and
josh peters it is unclear so far however
what kind of plot the two have written
down
still there's still some time before the
release as transformer 6 won't be out
until next year on june 24th
2022. more or less two years ago
pokemon detective pikachu hit theaters
the movie won the hearts of fans and
critics with its staging of various
pokemon and the story around private
detective pikachu and his partner tim
goodman
indeed even as the film was still
playing in theaters many raced voices
calling for a sequel
after remain unclear for a long time
whether warner brothers was working on a
sequel things are now looking
bad for the franchise in an interview
with inverse actor justice smith
recently announced that there are no
plans for a second part
although he really wishes for it he adds
that hope should be abandoned slowly
it would be a pity if that were the case
since ryan reynolds as the voice of
pikachu has convinced the fan community
what do you think would you like to see
a sequel to the most successful video
game adaption at the time
soon or have you already given up hope
please
let us know in the comments there
finally seems to be some progress in the
long overdue red sonia movie adaption
the hollywood reporter reports that
hannah john cayman has been cast as the
leading role of the fearless fighter
the 31 year old is certainly known to
many for her role as ghost and ant-man
and the wasp or as supporting actress
and latest tomb raider movie adaption
now then she is set to play red sonja
from the conan fantasy comics who has
been around since
1973 and has even become so popular over
the years that she got her
own comic book series what exactly the
film adaption will look like is
unfortunately still unclear but we hope
that after almost 10 years of production
trouble the ball will finally start
rolling
[Music]
foreign